this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armies museum in the uk
which houses a collection of thousands
of iconic weapons from throughout
history
and today he's taking yet another look
at the weaponry of battlefield
4. well that's very pleasing for as um
keeper of firearms and artillery
we've got a level here that i never saw
with quote unquote an
old cannon you can literally man this
thing and blow some poor sap away
if you want to see more of jonathan
reacting to battlefield guns make sure
to subscribe and check
out our videos in battlefield 1 and 5
and of course our previous episode on
the guns of battlefield 4.
if there are any other games guns or
mechanics that you guys want to see
jonathan breakdown let us know in the
comment section down below and if you'd
like to help out the royal army's museum
and continue to support jonathan's work
check out the links in the description
of this video right
over to jonathan
now we've seen the french famous assault
rifle
on the series before there's a two-tier
system established as there was for many
nations primary infantry rifles so you
had the
felon so networked war fighting
and all of that so you had a quite a
bulky looking
improved version of the fam ass that's
not what we see here
what we see here is the sort of this is
not to knock it in any way but the
budget option
so the very basic modern warfare
improvements
i mean that in the sense of actual
modern world and obviously not the game
the sort of bugle famous bugle style
carrying handle
was essentially cut off and the
picatinny optical sight rail that you
can see in the game
fitted in its place so it gives it a
rather a different profile
a little bit less bulky but the most
important thing is it allows you to
mount different optics which we see in
this clip
so something i noticed here is the
traditional fair mass had
a convertible ejection being a bullpup
with the working parts at the back of
the gun
you can't fire it from the left as a
left-hander
you can't easily shoot a bullpup from
the left shoulder because of the
hot brass being kicked out of the gun at
high speed is
not a good look for your face but what
we see here is
the cheek piece is fitted to the right
side of the gun
and the ejection port is open on the
left meaning that this is set up for a
left-hander so i think we've got a bit
of a legacy issue
of battlefield's weird relationship with
firearm
case ejection that we've covered in
previous episodes going back to
counter-strike we discovered
that it's set up for a left-hander but
it's being used by a right-hander
this one's a bit different but then
battlefield is quite famous for
the near future very near future setting
where you can throw in some speculative
current prototype things that are just a
bit interesting and different
hope or pretend that they actually get
adopted we've seen that with previous
entries in the series that we've covered
on this series so this is the lsat or
lightweight small arms technology light
machine gun
this specific program kind of did its
job and
disappeared into the background this was
a much more of a speculative
technology advancement program the
technology that textron have pioneered
in this
in the weapon we're seeing here is
really important for a long time
we all thought firearms technology had
plateaued leveled out
the idea was let's go to polymer cased
ammo
cased telescoped ammunition this had
been successfully fielded in artillery
and the next logical step was to put
into small arms that's what the lsat
machine gun was all about
and it did the job and so what you see
feeding into the gun
are plastic cylinders with propellant in
them with a primer on the back
and the bullet buried in the round and
this requires
whole new sets of technology for feeding
extracting and ejecting because you
haven't got a conventional tapered metal
case with a rim on the back
and companies like textron a couple of
others have
are if they haven't nailed it they are
very close so we are going to see case
telescope ammunition
i think in our future but clearly we
haven't adopted it yet so battlefield
was a little
premature
we've got now the kiapa rhino so this is
one of um very few revolvers that if you
haven't spotted is a bit upside down or
rather
the revolver fires from the bottom
chamber which means the barrel is set
very low
it's recoiling more straight back into
your hand and into your arm and so
depending on technique
it's much less likely to rise between
shots
and you don't have to muscle it down
back onto target to get your sight
picture back
so it does have a practical advantage it
isn't just a cool looking gun
although it is a cool looking gun and i
think it's primarily because it looks
cool
with that flattened there's flattened
sides to the cylinder the
upside down barrel the distinctive
silhouette
it is cropping up all over the place now
and it's
it fits that trope of the magnum
revolver because it is
a standard chambering at least is 357
magnum and that's what it's shown and
shown to be in
in the game but curiously the gun is
called
partly for legal reasons obviously sw40
which
has to refer to 40 smith and wesson
which is a
self-loading pistol cartridge which is
in elsewhere in the game in a different
gun
if you look very closely it's actually
40 smith and wesson or something close
to it
that is going into and falling out of
that
revolver when you reload it it's
definitely not a rimmed
magnum revolver cartridge so i presume
they slightly cheat cheaped out on um
acquiring another cartridge model or
maybe it was a mistake
i don't know i hesitate to criticize um
people who put in
thousands of hours of work into into a
game like this but it's
a nitpick the eagle eyed will have
spotted that the hammer doesn't move
that's actually correct and the hammer
is
not a traditional hammer it is more like
a
non-reciprocating cocking handle on a
rifle if that makes sense so you use it
to [ __ ] the weapon
but it does not reciprocate between
shots so overall
a pretty good representation of the
rhino it's just chambered in the wrong
ammo
the javelin anti-tank guided missile
system and from what i gather and what
i've seen
is the the basic configuration details
of the textures
are all pretty good as we've come to
expect of this
era of um first person to history and
the
aiming system the electro optical
guidance aiming system
looks right i think if you were to pull
up a screenshot of the actual
sighting system it would look right but
the way it works
uh now bf3 this was a
a fire and forget we know the term fire
and forget um
it's almost entered common speech uh
comes from
primarily from aircraft weapon systems
early missiles you had to guide them
onto target they were they were
typically radar guided the beauty of the
sidewinder was it was
fire and forget got a lock the sensor is
locked you launch the missile it does
its thing you can
carry on doing whatever it is you need
to do next that was a huge selling point
of that type of missile well the same is
true for anti-tank guided missiles
systems like the javelin being developed
in the 80s were
a real leap forward from what we had
before semi-automatic command to line of
sight
sack loss was that was the abbreviation
for this and that's pretty much what we
see here
so it's getting a lot but then you have
to maintain the lock
by moving with the target but the
javelin
isn't that the javelin is true fire and
forget so you get a lock you fire it
you can then get the hell away so that
you don't get engaged you don't get
counter-attacked or reload and engage a
different tank a different whatever it
is you're shooting at
so this is for presumably gameplay
reasons
balance with other anti-tank systems
it's reverting to an era of javelin that
as far as i know never
existed so an interesting thing to watch
fun to use i remember using it i don't
think i was aware when i was using it
that it was incorrect
so there you go
got here a new iteration of i guess a
battlefield favorite at this point
the russian aek 971 and russia keeps
returning to this idea of balanced
recoil or the balanced
action which is at the heart of the aek
971 you've got a reciprocating mass
at the front of the weapon going
forwards
cancelling out the reciprocating mass of
the bolt carrier
going backwards and if that's done
correctly
the only recoil left is the recoil
created by
the cartridge firing so all of that
about balance recoil is to say that
doesn't seem to actually be represented
in battlefield 4. there seems to be
a fair bit of recoil based on the on the
dispersion ticks
on the screen and the way it's handling
this thing does
have recoil so it's the way it's
balanced in game does not really reflect
its
real world role where if you had your
pick of rifles you might pick it
if you wanted to deliver accurate bursts
of automatic fire because your
the balanced recoil system helps with
that here
the gun's not doing much other than
looking cool
uh right so we've got the the shy tack
would be the correct pronunciation
although it's a little dicey in british
english and it's an american
manufacturer of anti-material rifles or
um
precision rifles i should say and i
think this is the m200 variant
it has that kind of distinctive
silhouette i think is why it's so
attractive
the thing that's that's caught my eye
here and has pinged
dim memories of playing bf4 is the
upgrade that flashes up
right at the end there so and i know
this isn't unique to the
intervention so this upgrade that popped
up is
nonsense it even shows you a picture of
the bolt quite a good rendition of the
interventions spirally cut bolt
that's a turn bolt that's that's
literally what they're showing you in
that
icon but they're calling it a straight
pull so this just isn't possible
bolt action rifles are designed around a
turning
locking bolt to make that work with a
straight pull bolt i suspect you could
design
a conversion system for a bolt-action
rifle for all i know someone has done it
but it would not be economically viable
it's not tactically necessary they are
used today as
precision rifles you don't need a
straightforward bolt in a precision
rifle
in the game of course it's just an
upgrade it's just a nod
to something from the real world and it
means you don't have to take your
virtual face off your virtual gun stock
so but i i acknowledge that coming up
with viable game
upgrades to bolt action rifles is
extremely difficult
beyond scopes bullet drop compensators
laser range finders
things that you could bolt onto the
weapon anything that's inherent to the
weapon
realistically it's not going to change
in military service so they have
massaged it
and they've taken inspiration from the
real world and crowbared it into this
weapon where it has no place being
this one is really intriguing because
this is one of a number of interesting
attempts to do something different with
the
ar-15 platform so as ever the idea here
this is from the from the aries the
company called ares in the states
and one of the ideas is you can use your
existing lower receivers which are the
serialized
firearm whether you're a civilian or a
military unit or
swat team or whatever so you could keep
the same weapon
and replace the upper receiver with
something new that would give you a
different capability
and what that capability is isn't seen
in battlefield 4 because
this is the ares 16 mission configurable
rifle
not set up as the machine gun version so
it has the upper receiver that allows
for
a belt-free top cover to be fitted but
it's not fitted in the game
so you have hints of what it could be
but it's still in its rifle
configuration
the idea here is that you can replace
the magazine
with a belt box a machine gun belt box
556
fit that to the magazine well just as a
convenient holder
and then feed in your belt of ammunition
into a belt feed top cover
so it adds a whole sort of layer of
modularity to the ar-15
as a weapons platform if we can call it
that so what it boils down to is
just a cool different assault rifle
right we've got a nice menu view of the
sks as it's represented in battlefield
4 here so i've immediately grabbed one
of our sks's
to do a bit of a comparison so this is
the this is actually both of these
believe it or not are the m59
66 those numbers relate to the year of
introduction and
modification and the country in question
is the former yugoslavia
but you can tell a yugoslav m59 from the
front end of the rifle
it's got the grenade launching spigot on
the front this is not a fancy flash
hider this is for slipping
the tail of a rifle grenade over
onto there and then you load the weapon
with
grenade launching cartridges so that
explains the differences up here
as to why it's a different difference of
the sks and why battlefield has taken
the
trouble to represent a different variant
then again they don't use it for rifle
grenade launching yugoslavia or serbia
are not factions in the game
so why make it specific to the m59
i suspect that's just the version of the
sks that they
googled when they looked for their
reference materials
yeah this is another weird one
battlefield's got this
interesting dichotomy of realistic
service weapons military military
service weapons and then
totally left field bonkers stuff and the
um
srss bulldog definitely falls into that
category because it's it's not a weapon
it's a
stock or chassis system and srss
actually stands for
short rifle stock systems which is the
name of the company
so they specialize in conversions for
other people's
rifles and in this case the donor or
victim
is an m14 and we know it's an m14
and not an m1a because it is automatic
which is the
biggest problem with this gun as far as
assessing it as
is it plausible or not goes because it's
it really seems to be quite controllable
on automatic fire and
762 nato is just not controllable in
automatic fire unless you have
a lot of skill and practice doing that
and most militaries don't afford you the
opportunity or the ammunition to do that
and you can only do it really in short
bursts
or from the hip
well that's very pleasing for as keeper
of firearms
and artillery as though although i often
stress i am much more of a small arms
specialist
we've got a level here that i never saw
playing bf4 of an
old fort with quote unquote an old
cannon
and it's not just that of a decoration
as they typically are you can literally
man this thing
and blow some poor sap away with
presumably a large piece of shot i don't
know what that's meant to be like a nine
pounder or something maybe even a 12
pounder i can't really tell
didn't get a good look at how accurate
it was as a representation of
an old piece of artillery but it's a
muzzleloader
cast a classic cannon what everyone
thinks of is it
the cannon your um civil war american
civil war napoleon
something of that nature that was a
little bit more advanced but essentially
the same thing that we've been using for
hundreds of years at this point so
really quite a primitive weapon to be
taken out with
and i dare say a little bit of
humiliation bonus
for for doing so and some style points
for for being the one to use it i think
yep it's our old friend the ansel
striker slash
protector street sweeper all basically
the same
shotgun in slightly different variants
as we've established on the series
before much more of a movie gun
than it ever has been a real world gun
what's interesting though
is the modification that's made in this
clip so we actually
have the duck bill attachment which i
don't think i've seen
for this type but will be easy enough to
make but someone already has for all i
know
so the original version of this idea was
much more of a
vacuum cleaner kind of nozzle flattened
this version is simply
two sort of metal tongues top and bottom
and then open either side
both what both systems do is constrain
the top of the shot pattern
and they sort of funnel more of the more
of the pieces of shot
into a lateral spread and more shots
going sideways than it is up and down
why well it gives you greater hip
probability
because you're typically going to be
aiming at chest tight and so this
does perform pretty well how they do in
real life
maybe a bit too efficient but it does a
pretty good job for a for a video game
and it even indicates to you in the
aiming reticle that you're going to get
this elongated
oval shot pattern quite a realistic
modification to a not very realistic
combat shotgun
if you'd like to check out the royal
armouries youtube channel i'm on that as
well
and we also have some stuff going on on
facebook and instagram that kind of
thing
by all means have a look at that we've
also got links in the description
for ways that you can help out the
museum in these slightly tricky times
if you can definitely come and visit us
we've got three sites in the uk
if you get the chance they're all worth
a look
[Music]
[Music]
you